ladies and gentlemen I have some very
serious news for you today there was an
Insurrection at the capital far-left
extremists in support of Gaza stormed
the cannon building and they were
subsequently arrested uh no one's really
calling it an Insurrection I mean people
are jokingly calling it Insurrection but
yeah several hundred far leftist stormed
the capital and uh got arrested but
they'll likely get a slap on the wrist
face no serious charges and be let go so
we'll talk about that though because
Rashida T was posting about how Israel
bombed Hospital killing hundreds of
civilians and it turns out that whole
story was a hoax and this is fascinating
because last night we're basically
debating it who did it was it Palestine
was it was it Israel and it turns out it
was nobody I mean technically it was
likely Hamas but it was a parking lot
fire no no joke video emerging after the
fact in daylight shows the hospital is
still intact was not leveled was not
damaged for the mo I mean minor damage
cosmetic damage but uh for the most part
it looks like it was a parking lot fire